would you be the bachelor
um you're an amazing woman
you've got awesome guys there so you
can't go wrong
thanks joe you have been eliminated on
the bachelorette and
it felt like such a quick 180 because
you'd had such a huge surge in fandom
after that wrestling date
and now we're seeing you sent home in
the moment
in time did it feel like a shocker to
you or how did you react
i was um i was sad i was actually pretty
sad it was such a beautiful experience
and
it really was a beautiful moment that we
had there amongst
the guys and but also like uh with with
keisha and with claire i mean
all of us escaped this pandemic reality
that we're living in and um
i think everybody appreciated that
moment and you know honestly i was
i was pretty upset when we when i left
you know i'm not sure you didn't get to
see it but um
yeah i shot some tears you did
what made you cry it was
just the um it was all of it it was just
knowing that this dream
i mean it we're in this the palm desert
in palm springs
and it was this dream world where there
were no masks and everyone was hugging
each other and everyone's around each
other just having a good time and the
point of this experience
was to find love it was this like
beautiful dream
or a mirage and it's like that mirage
like disappeared
and i got i knew i snapped back to
reality
so fast and i knew it was going to
happen
once i got didn't get the rose like
reality was just rushing back
and yeah it all hit me how much um how
awesome it was did you watch the
bachelor of the bachelorette before
um like you know in complete honesty i i
have never seen an episode of any of the
uh the franchise
wow you did not know what you were
getting into
just completely green and and i didn't
and i watched the episodes and i'm like
oh i was like wait like you you talked
to her for like eight minutes
and you like you're gonna make a move
it was just completely i treated this
like reality not reality
and um yeah it was just i'm i'm having a
lot of fun watching the strokes i'm like
oh oh like that's how fast it moves and
like oh that's how it looks
and even you wish anything you wish you
would have done differently what would
you have changed
knowing that now
that's like an interesting question i
mean in some ways nothing because
i being so unaware
of the whole i'm just of the bachelor
bachelor nation that the bachelor
franchise
i think i did go in pretty honest or
very honest and um
it's interesting part of the reason i
think i'm not on tv a lot i was thinking
about it because
i didn't know you're not supposed to
look at the camera so i i
would like be like because i thought
people they told me to act
real and in reality if hypothetically in
a
real situation if a camera is in front
of me or semi cameras in front of me i'm
gonna be like
i know i'm talking to somebody so like i
remember there was one time where
bennett was like um across his legs i
was like
guys are you looking at this man's shoes
right now his shoes cost more than my
whole suit like combined
and obviously not gonna show that
because that's how the show's about but
i looked in the camera
a lot and halper from the office
i was but because that's what any normal
person would do when they see cameras in
front of them they'd be like
like hey like it's like almost like a
proxy for a human being so anyway
um i am had i i kinda i'm still happy
that i
i keep i i was myself yeah and i'm not
sure how it would have changed if i
if i knew how the game was played kind
of so i i don't regret it at all it was
a it was a beautiful experience and uh
now that you know a little more about it
could we see you on bachelor in paradise
that's a good question i've been asked
that before and
i don't know when it's filming but i
will say
like i don't know the answer to that but
i hope i'm in a committed relationship
like a search relationship at some point
soon but uh again that's why i'm
sliding into your into your dms i would
imagine
um one or two one or two people have
been assigned to my dm's mostly my mom's
friends congratulating me
on being on the stroke
i am super single right now okay not
even tweeting anything
no not at all no okay if offered and if
you were single would you
go on bachelor in paradise are you
interested
it would definitely if i'm single at
that time um
i would definitely evaluate that option
who did you have stronger feelings for
claire or taisha
oh tasha no question i mean
when tasha came in it really was like a
whole the whole mood had changed
everyone got so super excited and she
just has this beautiful energy about her
um this aura about her that's like
that's undeniable
and from the moment she came from that
that when she was introduced
i think everybody was like whoa and also
from that first conversation everyone
was like whereas before dale was the
front where the clear front runner
everyone was kind of like
you know everyone was like kind of had
sympathy for each other everyone after
chase came in we had that first rose
that first ceremony
where we got to know her everyone was
like like i want her
it kind of it got real a lot realer once
tasha came in
and for good reason because she's so
she's an amazing woman
at this point of the guys who are left
give me a couple names who do you think
is a good guy for tasha
there are so many good guys and that's
what i told her when i was leaving i was
like man this is gonna be hard sister
for you
there's so many good guys but also you
know you can't go wrong
but if i had to pick a couple of guys i
would say one
the person that i fell in love with on
the show brendan
your bestie i mean i know we had that
moment but it goes beyond that i mean
brendan and i
um shared some really amazing
moments and and had we bonded a lot
during that time
on the show and i think he such a great
listener he's funny
he's obviously gorgeous and so he i
think he has a great
great shot ivan also really smart
very sweet great values i think ivan's
also somebody who
i root for and every time ivan or
brendan got a rose i
i know i smiled and was like like good
for you guys and um
i was so happy that they continued their
journey because they're good people
on the show and good people in real life
too claire
will you marry me yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
a lot of years for this taking it back
to claire and dale
there were moments that we saw where the
guys seemed frustrated with dale when i
was watching it i kind of felt like
i don't know i think they're more
frustrated with the situation what was
it like for you guys with dale in the
house were you guys
friendly with him did you think he was
genuine did you think he was there for
the right reasons what was the true vibe
so i think from the very onset from when
once dale got that first impression rose
he had a target on his back and um
as they said you know heavy is the head
that wears the crown and
everyone knew he was the top dog it's
very obvious he was top dog
not and for good reason i mean the
hell's a stunt
the hell is very well spoken very good
looking and so
for a good reason he was honestly ahead
of the pack
yeah from the first night and so for
that reason
yeah that the house was a bit
contentious with dale
on and off the camera at times but i
think
now everyone realizes and is happy for
dale and claire
and everyone realizes like hey like
everyone's playing the game
and for claire you just might have been
a little bit better and i think
and that the great thing about this
group of guys is like we're all a little
bit older
that doesn't always mean more mature but
i think these guys really were a bit
more mature
i agree i think everyone understands
that they're like everyone understood
there were no like after day left no one
was like yo
like like like at that guy like everyone
was happy
for them to have gone and we were happy
to move on the
question of course we know matt james is
the next bachelor but
you've got some fandom building around
you
i think especially if you go on paradise
if you stay single i don't know
would you be the bachelor um i'm gonna
answer the same way i said about
paradise like i i hope
you know again tomorrow's never granted
and so i hope i
don't have to answer that question um
but it's a very flattering question to
be asked um anybody in
bachelor nation you would want to date
sometimes relationships just come out of
this franchise because people meet
people doing things
that's a great question i don't know
bachelor nation so i can't answer that
question but
but if anybody in bachelor nation wants
to like hang out and talk
like i'm here for it like get at me
you